hello guys it's Greg Gregory the Alba
here what's your name what's your net ID
o net Monette not Greg not Greg
vegetable imma believe that she's as
great as me my net came on forever ago
and I had to take the videos down
because Ryan crossed the line a little
too much a little too much um it happens
I'm back yeah she's back ready to
forgive me and to move forward in life
and I thought all right since phone Nets
back we're gonna start off with rack or
a cos real life Street Fighter this came
out a while ago um you have not played
Street Fighter right no okay I'm gonna
tell you who rack a racket is real fast
okay they're a sketch comedy channel
cool and they tend to do sketches that
can sometimes turn out a little dark and
violent oh yeah okay and I thought hey
what a great way to making a new first
impression I'm a champ
yeah she does yoga incredibly good at it
thank you one two three
Oh looks like somebody needs a saucy
booties a Nega
you
you're not calling anybody
Oh
Oh
Michael Russia
I will weep when our number world to
destroy sorry what did you eat me that
with a bow
we win
you
oh dang wise that's definitely more of a
treat for me than it was for you and I
know all the characters that were there
you do stunts and stuff right I do I
come from a stunt background and a lot
of those were really impressive
yeah that's one thing that's I met the
main guy the guy I played really the
white than the red bandanna cool yeah he
can he and I asked him like about his
background he said he doesn't have a
background in stunts or anything like
they start like most of their sketches
can be very gruesome and violent in this
one you know like was definitely pg-13
which that was with all the junk grabs I
have not seen some other some of the
sketches well why don't you um no it's
cool to see you like man this is a guy
who's just a fan of like making fun
stuff and like action films and
everything and you know to see like damn
be evolvement there's clearly wire
effects in there yeah CGI was like the
arms yeah
they started off just threatening they
started off just like filming at their
home and now their channels got and like
evolved so much that they're upping
their budget and I don't know it's kind
of inspiring to see that I think it's
really inspiring and the fact that they
had a car there to just mess up yeah
kick where's your car
oh my car don't beat it up if you if you
ever did anything to betray me in some
way moan at or hurt me I would
absolutely destroy your car right away
my fact I plant c4 in there to watch you
drive away thinking you're safe and then
blow it up that is not the nice it might
not be the nicest thing but that's how I
am I I like to get revenge
I'm a very revenge driven individual ah
well we'll work on that
that's what you say yeah it seems like
they're hiring actors who actually know
how to like that's the cool thing it's
like beyond it being funny like there's
some like legit moves like they they
were getting actual moves from the video
game and there
and then they were having their own
choreographer room like looks like a
rather cool fight actually yeah I saw
some little high Falls and awesome kicks
I thought that was really cool
what's a wirework - what's a high pole a
high fall um if your you could fall off
of anything really into like boxes or an
airbag or porta pits fallentin air bed
yes like a car airbag hmm well but a lot
bigger that's what they do in movies
like when like my brother had to do it
on a TV show once where he jumped off a
building into an air bag no wires or
anything
Wow yeah he survived he did yeah he's a
good-looking guy yes every you know it's
you two look very different but you're
both like really good-looking how do you
like normally it's like well yeah this
one's pretty but the other one you know
it's like eg tits brother and sister you
guys look totally different but like he
is very handsome he's a very handsome
guy we both have glasses now as well I
think I'm attracted to him more than you
me too
that's my net anyway dudes and dudettes
uh if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe today and become a reject and
monnet Moyo has a new channel up sweet
eats for the health of it for the health
and it her and another pretty female
what's her name again
Jessie Jessie um she's the blonde one
and she's brunette but they both have
really awesome personalities and know a
lot about health and how to make
delicious healthy food yeah we love
sweets and we wanted to show how you can
make eating healthy fun yeah exactly
cuz I'm like a big McDonald's guy like
their king
taco well jack-in-the-box Wendy's Oh
sexy chicken sandwich I will show you
later
you got marked on our Channel and we'll
show you how to how to how to clean that
up and you come on my channel and I'll
show you how I live
both dart now
you have a Twitter right I do um I'm
more on my Instagram there you go if you
wanted to do that it's at Manette boyo
mm-hmm no jokes no jokes olenin uh
believe me I
okay nevermind